i don't know
like ladies you know when you got to
dinner with a guy like just because you
bought me dinner doesn't mean i owe you
sex and that's true but just because you
let me have sex with you doesn't mean i
owe my morning
right it's the same exact transaction
equality
i don't know that's why it's weird women
go we're just as horny as men yeah maybe
a lot more requirements ladies quite a
checklist you're like the goldilocks of
dick this guy's too short this guy's too
dumb this guy's just right guys we'll
[ __ ] the porch
and i'm not saying one is better words
just different
i go to the doctor he's like what
happened i was like it was too hot
but look i get it you know it's got to
be tough to be a lady i feel like women
are getting screwed in the orgasm
department i feel like men are having
way more orgasms than women and that
sucks people talk about the wage gap the
orgasm gap is out of control
you gals are getting 77 cents to the
boner
like if a woman had to have an orgasm to
get pregnant there'd be like two people
here
and you get nothing for your orgasm
ladies like if a guy is an orgasm go and
get pregnant carry a baby for nine
months deliver the baby then breastfeed
the baby and all the guy to do is this
good
and he tried really hard not do that
it's a horrible setup for the woman the
guy is all the fun the girl does all the
work that'd be like if i ate a whole
chocolate cake and the girl gained
weight then she went to the gym and i
got buff
gotta be tough
plus women constantly judged by your
looks that's gotta be exhausting
constantly judged by your looks but you
all know to look good you all look great
that's how women figured out to take the
selfie up here that was all you ladies
you know your good sight lines are
i think that's why women like tall guys
just some guy looking at you from your
best angle 100 percent of the time all
day long that's why you don't hook up
with short guys there's some guy like
geez look at the triple chin on this
broad oh
you like a tall man ladies and that's
okay that's how you're wired you're all
a bunch of height supremacists yeah
that was always the first question back
on the dating apps you over six feet you
over six feet over six feet i felt bad
after a while if i like to come up with
something i was like well no but if it
helps i'm still growing as a person
eventually i got annoyed with one girl's
like how much do you weigh she was like
whoa that's body shaming it's hard for
me to lose weight it's even harder for
me to gain height
like you gals get so down about your
looks but you can do so many amazing
things you never really brag about let's
go through a list of stuff women can do
that's unbelievable first of all you can
make people
that's insane people are coming out of
you alive
you'd be bragging about that constantly
i know men will take a photo of a good
[ __ ]
you're making human beings
how annoying would men be if they could
make people i made him him men named
kids absolutely they didn't do anything
that's jimmy jr oh yeah what'd you do i
came
she didn't i got to do everything around
here yeah
ladies you can feed people that's
bananas you got grade a vitamin d
organic milk on tap
we got a cup of coffee right here
bowl of cereal i got you
you're a [ __ ] dairy
i know a girl she's lactose intolerant
still producing milk
she's making some she can't even
tolerate
much like my mom do with me
[Music]
ladies you live longer than men and you
have a higher threshold for pain than
men on paper you're like a superhero
on paper
but that's the thing you ladies are so
incredible you're such amazing beings
yeah you're some of the most insecure
people i've ever met it's always about
looks do i look good and this is turning
you on you like that you look fat and
this is doing before what about this uh
what are you getting you're a woman own
it
wouldn't be the cockiest [ __ ] on the
planet
what do you have a paper cut
i've been bleeding for three days
this [ __ ] guy huh what else you got
oh you cut yourself shaving oh
last week an immigrant waxed my taint
let's say you push out a kidney stone oh
i pushed out a little league player how
do you like that they give me those
froot loops
but one of the most amazing things about
women the thing you get no credit for
ladies the most unbelievable impressive
thing is your ability to hide everything
everything's a goddamn secret you're all
in the cia you have the real you then
you let us see
we'll go with menstruation pretty big
deal let's start there you hide it
pretty goddamn well
men are clueless we have to guess
is that time of the month what do you
think
time of the month is she acting weird do
you have anything to town on you realize
that men got there there'd be blood
everywhere on the walls the sidewalk
everywhere
everywhere just guy's walking to work a
[ __ ] uterine lining jesus christ
holy hell god damn it give me one of
those masculine napkins thank you yeah
oh yeah you too huh jeff guess we're
synced up yeah there we go all right
here we go
says don't flush it but [ __ ] it
it's all hidden everything's hidden
i used to work in an office in midtown
manhattan i was the only guy on the
floors meeting like 100 women i never
heard one fart not a toot not a queef
nothing
nothing
sometimes on friday i'd bring in chili
and just wait
nothing i farted up here eight times
tonight
i walked in on one win once once taking
a [ __ ] it was like i walked in on a
murder scene she was like get the [ __ ]
off
jesus christ take it easy you're allowed
to [ __ ] i'm the opposite walking on me
[ __ ] i'm like hey what'd you bring
nothing you're giving us nothing ladies
all your sexual stuff that's all under
wraps very hush-hush men walker i'm an
ass man i'm a boob man never see a woman
go i'm a ball gal yeah
i love that sack
nothing
giving us nothing then you want us to
know how you're feeling and stuff what
are you kidding we're in the dark
sometimes i read a cosmo a woman's
magazine just get some inside dirt one
time i was reading a cosmo there's a
full page article on how to go down on a
woman properly
it's like this should be in like guns
and ammo or in the stream
sports illustrated teach us late we want
to please
god damn you got fake eyelashes hair
extensions spanx foundation you should
know what i'm thinking i don't know you
[ __ ] look like
that's why it's weird when a woman's
like you want to have sex with me i get
to know me first get to know you you're
wearing three pounds of jewelry clown
makeup and holding a fart for four weeks
i don't know who the hell you are
that's why it's so important to have sex
it's not because we're horny psycho
animals we are but it's important cause
you finally see behind the curtain for
the first time and it's glorious ladies
your hair is messed up you're naked
yelling out filthy obscenities you're
like damn who's this
your friend calls hey it took a month
but you banged sarah how was it great i
finally met her
he's like oh man all right we'll come
over we'll talk about him i can't she
won't let me leave
thanks a lot i'm kevin hart you guys are
great what a crowd thank you so much for
coming out i appreciate it praise allah
get home safe i'm gay thank you have a
good night sweep it up l.a i love you